alors comme tu es responsable de la
jeunesse sur la chaîne de télévision la
plus regardée de france
j'ai de faire une interview moralité
pour savoir à qui nous confions nos
enfants d'accord alors première question
as tu déjà piqué quand tu étais petit
dans le porte-monnaie ta maman oui à
est ce que tu as déjà fouiller dans les
poches de la personne avec qui tu vivais
j'ai souvent failli j'ai maintenant je
suis allé jusqu'au bout c'est pas bien
même dans la banlieue
et tu déjà sortie avec la copine d'un
copain et gâteaux pinios a dû m'arriver
ouais ouais on ne citera l'ordre du
mérite jean pour une action de bravoure
que t'as pas commis cet été là mais
c'est pas toi qui a fait le geste qui a
sauvé dit que c'est pas moi c'était
vraiment comme ça mais j'ai désolé
couteau pose d'autres questions moi je
sais pas non mais non je sais que je te
fais des tables moralité n'arrête pas de
le faire des réponses moral marie
morel tu trouves je suis à venir tu
trouves à un nourrisson abandonné sur un
bailleur souvent ses cauchemars erreur
tu vois certes l'idée de trouver un
moment tu fais des cauchemars c'est pas
ça vient d abandonner qu'est ce que t'en
fait jugement c'est toi ou l'orphelinat
est ce tu fais pas je prayssas que ce
soit moi mes
responsabilités
mais y'a peut pas dire ça à la télé
parce que les gens vont les déposer ci
contre des fois tu joue aux cartes chez
toi avec ta maquilleuse les gens qu'il
fallait que toi tu triches oui tu
trouves ça moral de triche avec des gens
qui sont des employés oui parce qu'on
triche elle aussi est riche pour être
sûr de ne rien rater de l'ina l'institut
abonnez vous mettez un pouce bleus